[Música]
el gobierno de presidente yo vayan
ordenó un bombardeo en siria contra
milicias iraníes pro iraníes el ataque
deja al menos 17 muertos y es el primero
ordenado tras la posesión del demócrata
hace cinco semanas el pentágono lo
justificó como represalia por los
ataques con cohetes contra tropas
estadounidenses en irak
las vacunas cubanas contra el coi 19
soberana 2 y abdalá comienzan la etapa
de ensayos de la fase 3 la próxima
semana el gobierno cubano dice estar
preparado para este reto científico y
espera fabricar 110 millones de dosis de
soberana 2 y vacunar a toda su población
antes de que termine el año
continuamos con nuestra serie sobre los
recicladores en américa latina y españa
hoy vamos a san salvador donde el
reciclaje se convirtió en una
oportunidad de trabajo para los jóvenes
de ese país y para poder alejarse de la
violencia según datos del banco mundial
la pobreza disminuyó en los últimos años
en el salvador pero todavía los jóvenes
sufren de la falta de oportunidades
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos al menos 17 combatientes de
milicias pro iraníes murieron este
viernes en un bombardeo estadounidense
en la provincia de day la el sur en el
este de siria así lo informó el
observatorio sirio de derechos humanos
en el que sería el primer ataque
ordenado por el presidente joe wright en
desde su llegada al poder hace cinco
semanas la ong anunció a través de un
comunicado que todas las bajas
pertenecen a la fila de las milicias
iraquíes multitud popular y catai
hezbollah respaldadas por irán el
bombardeo de esta madrugada tuvo como
objetivo posiciones de estos grupos y un
cargamento de armas
el pentágono explicó que esta acción es
la respuesta a recientes ataques contra
tropas estadounidenses y desde la
coalición internacional que lucha contra
el grupo yihadista estado islámico en
irak por su parte rusia cuando el
bombardeo y llamó al respeto y
condicional de la soberanía e integridad
territorial siria
previamente conversamos en washington
dice con nuestro corresponsal cristóbal
vázquez que nos dio más detalles veamos
claro y el bombardeo iba a hacer aún más
grande pero fue el propio baile que dijo
que no simplemente iba a aceptar un
govern bandeo menor al que estaba
planeado por el pentágono bombardeo fue
a las 2 de la mañana hora de siria 6 de
la tarde hora de washington se usaron
siete bombas de 500 libras cada una para
bombardear edificios de estas milicias
pro iraníes y también un punto de
frontera no oficial entre irak y siria
donde se contrabandeaban según el
pentágono armas y personal militar según
el pentágono esto se hace en reacción a
este ataque del 15 de febrero en el
norte de irak en ebril alea aeropuerto
donde hay murieron un contratista
filipino aliado a estados unidos y la
colisión de eeuu en irak y también
resultaron heridos varios
estadounidenses según oficiales del
pentágono y fuentes de inteligencia este
ataque
hecho el 15 de febrero contra las
fuerzas estadounidenses en irak fue
hecho por un grupo llamado las los
guardianes de la sangre y precisamente
los ataques entonces de anoche fueron
respuesta a este ataque del 15 de
febrero
continuamos en eeuu donde el presidente
joe biden conversó ayer jueves con el
rey de arabia saudita salman bin
abdulaziz antes de la publicación de un
esperado informe en la inteligencia
estadounidense sobre el asesinato el
periodista saudí está llama al show y se
espera que el documento confirme la
implicación del príncipe heredero
mohammad bin salman en el asesinato del
comunicador en el consulado del reino en
la ciudad turca de estambul en la
llamada ambos recordaron el carácter
histórico de la alianza entre riad y
washington y bailén se comprometió a
trabajar para que la relación bilateral
sea lo más fuerte y transparente posible
las vacunas cubanas contra el kobe 19
soberana 2 y abdalá empezarán ensayos de
fase 3 la próxima semana unas pruebas
clínicas que coinciden con el inicio de
su fabricación mientras la isla caribeña
espera fabricar 110 millones de estas
dosis de soberana 2 y vacunar a toda su
población antes de que finalice el 2021
un reto para el cual el gobierno cubano
se siente preparado informados muñoz
la primera vacuna anti kobe de américa
latina podría llegar pronto q va a
comenzar a entre el 3 y el 8 de marzo la
fase 3 de ensayos clínicos en las
soluciones de soberana 2 y abdalá la
última fase antes de su validación unas
pruebas que serán simultáneas al inicio
de la producción industrial de las
vacunas expertos cubanos se muestran
esperanzados y también han demostrado en
la inclusión de una potente respuesta
inmunológica las vacunas cubanas están
desarrolladas con la técnica de la
proteína recombinante que consiste en
estimular la respuesta del sistema
inmune científicos destacaron que no
habrá límite en el número de dosis por
lo que se podrá inmunizar cada seis
meses cuba está trabajando en otras dos
soluciones
la soberana uno que ha concluido su
primera fase de estudios y mont visas
que se aplica mediante spray nasal hace
unos días la isla caribeña anunció que
espera empezar la vacunación masiva en
su población antes de que acabe el
primer trimestre cuando sólo si todo
sale bien este año debemos vacuna
los incubar el país ha controlado el
avance del cob y 19 durante
prácticamente toda la pandemia sin
embargo tras la reapertura de
aeropuertos en octubre se produjeron
rebrotes que obligaron a detener la des
escalada actualmente cuenta con cerca de
50.000 casos y más de 300 fallecidos
cuba dedica una cuarta parte de su
presupuesto a la salud con una gran
apuesta por la biotecnología como
demuestra el desarrollo de vacunas en el
pasado para la meningitis ve el cáncer
de pulmón y los tumores sólidos entre
otras soluciones brasil superó ya a los
250.000 muertos por kobe 19 el gigante
latinoamericano se convierta así en el
segundo país en superar esta cifra
después de estados unidos que reúne ya a
507 mil 400 muertes por la enfermedad la
nación supera este umbral justo cuando
hoy se cumple un año de haber coincidido
con el primer caso de kobe 19 en medio
del peor brote registrado hasta el
momento en ese país además el impacto de
las nuevas variantes del virus más
contagiosas preocupa a las autoridades
esto en medio de una nueva ola de
contagios
de vacunas y también medidas de
contención del gobierno de bolsonaro
tildadas de insuficientes
esta guerra es la corte internacional de
justicia de la haya realizan la primera
audiencia sobre la contienda entre
venezuela y guyana por la región del
esequibo una disputa que lleva casi dos
siglos el territorio de casi 160.000
kilómetros cuadrados se representa dos
tercios de la superficie de guyana y es
rico en petróleo y otros minerales
mientras caracas reclama su soberanía
como herencia de la época colonial
georgetown asegura que la polémica
limítrofe fue saldada con un laudo de
parís de 1899 federico de barbaria no
nos entrega las claves para entender
esta disputa
el esequibo la manzana de la discordia
entre guyana y venezuela el territorio
de 159 mil kilómetros cuadrados
corresponde a dos tercios de la
superficie de guyana es un área rica en
petróleo minerales y biodiversidad
venezuela reclama su soberanía en la
zona porque formó parte de la
organización territorial colonial y se
amparan en uti possidetis iuris un
principio legal del derecho
internacional que otorga a los estados
el control de territorios que les
pertenecen geográfica e históricamente
mientras que guyana defiende que el
territorio fue adquirido por grán
bretaña en 1814 mediante un tratado con
países bajos ante la poca claridad de
los límites el explorador robert john
burck por encargo de londres realizó un
trazado que ampliaba el control
británico una línea que se fue
extendiendo en otras etapas el primer
reclamo lo hizo venezuela en 1814
denunciando la incursión del imperio
británico y con el apoyo de eeuu bajo la
doctrina monroe que reclamaba una
américa para los americanos empujada por
washington venezuela aceptó recurrir a
un arbitraje internacional que desembocó
en el llamado laudo arbitral de parís en
mil
199 este fallo fijó los límites actuales
pero caracas no lo reconoce luego de que
en 1949 se conociera documentación sobre
un presunto arreglo político entre
estadounidenses británicos y el jurista
ruso friedreich martens el 17 de febrero
de 1966 3 meses antes de la
independencia de guyana se firmó el
acuerdo de ginebra tratado aún vigente
que reconoce el reclamo de venezuela y
busca encontrar soluciones
ese pacto mantuvo el statu quo pero no
resolvió la disputa la cual se reavivó
bajo la presidencia de hugo chávez y más
aún desde 2015 cuando fueron
descubiertos sus vastos yacimientos
petrolíferos en guyana en 2018
georgetown introdujo un reclamo ante la
corte internacional de justicia que en
diciembre de 2020 se declaró competente
para fallar sobre la legitimidad del
laudo de parís pero venezuela considera
nulo ese laudo y no reconoce la
intervención de la cei j
caracas insiste en su reclamo de
soberanía y en enero de este año elevó
las tensiones al detener a dos barcos
pesqueros guyaneses acusándolos de
navegar en aguas soberanas venezolanas
así la disputa que ha tenido altos y
bajos a lo largo de la historia parece
lejos de resolverse en el corto plazo
continúan las protestas en níger en
áfrica occidental tras la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales
consideradas el domingo celebradas el
domingo la comisión electoral del país
ha declarado a mohamed bazoum vencedor
de los comicios pero el líder de la
oposición hizo fútbol mohammad u también
se declara ganador el gobierno culpa a
la oposición de la violencia de esta
semana que deja dos muertos y cientos de
detenidos
enfrentamientos en la capital niamey
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
partidarios del candidato de la
oposición mahaman usman que se declara
ganador de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales las protestas
que han dejado al menos dos muertos
también se han desatado en la ciudad de
dosso donde a principios de esta semana
se incendió la oficina de un partido
progubernamental el gobierno culpa a
hama amadou por los disturbios el líder
de la oposición no pudo presentarse a
las elecciones presidenciales pero apoya
a mahamat guzmán el jueves el ministro
del interior de níger dijo que las
fuerzas de seguridad habían detenido a
más de 400 personas un grupo que incluía
a políticos
se ha detenido varios de ellos el
principal responsable y se está buscando
el principal responsable pero como
siempre yo me coma
en fin
con el telón de fondo de las protestas
unos desconocidos incendiaron varias
viviendas entre ellas la de un veterano
periodista de radio france
internationale un ataque que el estado
atribuye a la oposición con la salida
del presidente y su fuma amaiur tras
diez años en el mandato
níger se encuentro en medio de su
primera transición de poder elegida
desde la independencia y mientras la
comisión electoral del país dice que la
votación la ganó mohamed bazum el ex
ministro del interior la oposición
impugna al resultado
y sumamos el régimen del señor hizo fue
mahamadou quiere confiscar sin
escrúpulos la voluntad del pueblo que se
ha expresado mayoritariamente a mi favor
en la segunda vuelta
los observadores de la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental han dicho que las elecciones
se han celebrado en condiciones libres
junto con naciones unidas la unión
regional ha condenado la violencia y ha
instado a todas las partes a dar
muestras de contención la nueva comisión
electoral de mianmar designada por la
junta militar responsable del golpe de
estado
los resultados de las elecciones
legislativas celebradas el pasado
noviembre en las que obtuvo una amplia
victoria la liga nacional para la
democracia el partido de la depuesta
líder aún sanssouci las supuestas
irregularidades en las elecciones que le
dieron una victoria por mayoría absoluta
al partido de succi con el 83% de los
476 asientos del legislativo han sido la
razón de la junta militar para perpetrar
este golpe de estado el pasado primero
de febrero las protestas civiles en las
calles del país en rechazo al golpe han
cobrado la vida de al menos cuatro
personas en medio de la represión de las
fuerzas de seguridad
y seguimos con nuestra serie sobre los
recicladores hoy vamos a san salvador
donde el reciclaje se convirtió en una
oportunidad de trabajo para jóvenes
salvadoreños y así alejarse de la
violencia de las pandillas este
reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones de resultado de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo y ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gao y la actitud de red el
informe es de claudia chicas
y dedicarse al reciclaje para estos
jóvenes que trabajan en un centro de
acopio de desechos en la capital de el
salvador representa una oportunidad
digna para pagar sus estudios y tener un
mejor futuro de vida para mí sería sacar
mi área
seguirán lo que
sólo que haya el diferente
[Música]
como la vida de aves
ahora ya que es muy diferente
según datos del banco mundial la pobreza
ha ido disminuyendo en estos últimos
años en el salvador pero todavía los
jóvenes salvadoreños sufren de la falta
de oportunidades laborales y algunos
caen en la violencia de las pandillas
jóvenes como rodrigo encuentran en el
reciclaje una forma de vivir legal y
alejada de esa violencia
así como para nosotros los jóvenes es
algo complicado pero como ahí también
depende de la persona de lo que anda
haciendo así como nosotros nosotros no
andamos así en cosas ilícita entonces no
tenemos que preocuparnos si nos sale uno
no sale no si no sale bueno yo nos
protege porque él sabe lo que andamos
haciendo con trabajo digno en 2020 tras
13 años de lucha entró en vigor una ley
integral de gestión de desechos sólidos
la nueva ley podría formalizar entre
3000 y 5000 recolectores también abrirá
un camino más en la formalidad para
rodrigo michelle y sus compañeros hace
que el informativo buen día
[Música]